[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
shadow of the Tomb Raider is upon us and
this is the third game in Lara Croft's
origins trilogy so we're closing off her
story from the start and we're gonna be
streaming about an hour of shadow the
Tomb Raider from the beginning and here
to do that with me is senior brand
director rich Briggs screenings how are
you Michael doing good to see you man
good to see you as well
so yeah we're gonna be jumping into the
beginning of the game could you kind of
like lay the groundwork for what's going
on with shadow the Tomb Raider
absolutely so as you mentioned this is
the conclusion to Lara Croft's origin
story and so we look at this as her
defining moment and this is Lara Croft
at her most capable her most calculating
ever and so since we've given her more
Skills than ever before we have to up
the stakes across the board so when
you're talking about combat this is
Trinity's best going after her so you've
got to have the best tactics like
covering yourself of camouflage you've
got to have the best tombs so they are
scarier than ever before traps
everything in and will kill you the
world stakes are higher this is Lara
Croft trying to stop the Maya apocalypse
the exploration is more difficult so
really it is us taking everything just
to the limit and giving Lara Croft her
biggest challenge ever all right sounds
good man
so do we want to do want to get a little
bit of that yeah absolutely
let's jump into this now I'm gonna be
playing so I might have a little bit of
difficulty trying to talk and play at
the same time I'm not too good at that
but rich is gonna be actually taking
questions so if anyone out there is in
the chat watching we're going to we have
a couple people looking at the chat so
if you're curious about anything for
child the Tomb Raider make sure you say
something in the chat and maybe we'll
pull it up and we'll talk about it
because uh we're gonna play for about an
hour or so so we have a lot of
and there's a lot to uncover with shout
Tomb Raider so you were mentioning
earlier that it's available for those
who bought special editions or out early
accents that's correct so right now the
early access is live so if you have the
Croft edition or the season pass you
could actually keep playing right now
okay for everyone else the game goes
live on Fridays and the 14th and 17th we
are incredibly excited to finally get
the game in people's hands yeah so it's
gonna be Xbox one ps4 and PC that is
correct
and we are playing on xbox 1x I believe
I have this set for a high frame rate
mode because I think we're only stream
in 1080p so you can go see the the 4k on
there but I really like having those
options you know high frame rate is
always what I go with when I'm playing
on ps4 Pro or an Xbox 1x the game of
that option on frame rate so absolutely
and you can switch back and forth on the
fly that's the thing that I love about
it so I personally play on the high
resolution mode throughout most of the
experiences of them whenever I get into
combat situations I switch over to the
high frame rate yeah so for me I love
that you know that that native 4k image
it is just so and wastefully really rich
and lush it just makes the world as
immersive as possible especially for
shadow tomb raider where absolutely no
you guys are going to Central America
and South America and there's a lot of
you know vegetation and all that like
horizons and weather effects like it
just look it looks like I played about
the first five hours of this game
already so luckily I'll know what to do
but in those moments I was just like wow
this is a like you really built out this
world and really use graphical
capabilities isn't I like it as much as
you possibly could so game looks great
thank you playing for 4k will look even
better I love it and you know we things
like the true HDR support you know true
3d audio with Dolby Atmos I mean we
really wanted to make the world as as
immersive as possible and you mentioned
the foliage we've got yes sander dynamic
foliage so when we when we took Lara
Croft into the jungle we wanted to make
sure that it was coming alive
because we really do view the world as a
character and it is it is protecting its
secrets that is pushing back against
Lara Croft because she's one of the few
people that can go into these harsh
fireman's she has the skills she has a
will she has the intelligence to survive
where most people would would die quite
frankly I would not last five minutes in
the situation is that Laura is it yeah
even in the in the early hours we'll see
how many close calls that she ends up
getting herself into
yeah well you can see she's already got
herself in one now so we kicked this off
by trying to dig ourselves out of uh
what is she she's like she said as she
was gonna collapse yeah and so the whole
point is you don't even know and we
don't explain you know how she got to
this moment were that were the tomb
around her is collapsible we wanted to
do from the very beginning is just show
you that Lara Croft is feeling very very
confident almost to a fault so she has
separated from Jonah
Jonah's saying hang on let me let me
call for help and she's saying no she
loses the trail so this is us
establishing from the very beginning
that Lara feels like she's the only one
who can stop Trinity and as you're gonna
see later that's gonna have some pretty
significant calm yeah she's definitely
shadowing yeah I know
well I will definitely get to that
moment if you haven't seen it already I
know that even if you don't have the
game yet you may have seen kind of what
happens in the early hours but I really
get the feeling that Lara's increasingly
stubborn I mean she's always had that
drive to like fail what Trinity's up to
and like seek out these ancient relics
and all that but I feel like in shadow
here in particular she's like you know
she's like no I'm doing this my way and
I'm not I'm not gonna listen to Jonah
it is there's a there's a little bit of
that confidence that I was talking about
there's a little bit of that
stubbornness in there part of it you can
see is justified those laura has been
through so much so she really is one of
the few people in the world that can
stop Trinity but what we're trying to
showcase in shadow of the generator is
that it's gotten almost to a fault right
so as you mentioned Lara is gonna make a
decision about taking the artifact later
that is gonna trigger the Maya
apocalypse and and that is a result of
her feeling like I have to do this I
have to be the one to stop Trinity and
and I love across the narrative these
moments where you will get her even
butting up against Jonah
you know Jonah has been there for her
for so long her one of her dearest
friends the fact that this game strains
even their relationship I think is very
telling about where Laura is in her in
her narrative Greta yeah definitely and
I so I have we have a questions document
where we're pulling up yeah some
questions we've got one here so it says
what is the process like when building
out this world working to create places
with cultural act accuracy yeah so when
we're building out the world like we
talked about it is you know absolutely
trying to make it as immersive and
experience as possible we also want to
make sure that that we call it sort of
Google myths you know we want it to feel
like it's rooted in history rooted in
culture but not necessarily historically
accurate
that's about supporting the narrative
that we want to that we want to tell but
we did send the team to Mexico we did
work with a cultural consultation group
we worked with a historian so we do want
to make sure that it feels even if not
exactly what happened then it could have
happened yeah like it comes from a place
of authenticity like exactly you'll have
a lot of I notice too when playings like
there's a lot of like Spanish everyone's
like speaking Spanish and that there's
also a mode where you can have the
characters speak Spanish yes so the
immersion mode will allow you to to not
have the subtitles or have people speak
in English when they're interacting with
with Lara so the idea is that it really
just tries to draw you into the world
yeah that's that's that's pretty cool
for me like seeing different cultures
like represented in these games so yeah
having that that kind of that cultural
accuracy or a fat like a sound
foundation to build off of I think is a
lot of people will appreciate so great
yeah and I think that like we're not
gonna be able to make it to PI CT but I
know I've heard what it is to be so it
is and PI DT we actually have a video
online that shows a little bit of a
walkthrough of Pyke TT it's not right
much of it even though it's a ten minute
video it's still only showing a sliver
of what sin PI PT because it is the
biggest hub that we've ever delivered a
numerator
and probably you guys that are out there
looking to do the hundred percent
completion that is when you were gonna
spend the majority of your time I mean
there's just dozens of hours of gameplay
it is you know it's a 30 plus our
experience overall and PI TT has just a
wealth of side quests and challenge
tombs and collectibles there's there's
so much to do that yeah yeah it's them
it's not necessarily open world for
those who may not be familiar with where
the this new trilogy has gone it's not
necessarily open world but there are
like big hug worlds where you do take
the west and you look kind of branch off
almost like Metroidvania ish I I know
people who use Adwords for games where
you kind of like go up along branching
paths for different like progression and
stuff like that and we saw a god of war
do that when it came back around this
year yeah absolutely
like and I love the portion because what
we try and do is make sure that you've
got an a rollercoaster of a narrative
you know that core campaign you always
know from one moment to the next what
your next story beat is but then we can
pause the narrative and we try and do it
in a relatively believable way you know
some people say yeah well hey the my
apocalypse is coming why are you
stopping to collect a bunch of you know
yeah a bunch of things in pi TT but we
try and make it believable where the
side quests that you're doing and the
challenge tombs that you're that you're
exploring these are all giving you
either knowledge or experience or
artifacts or even weapons that you can
then use to make lara stronger and make
her you know more prepared for that for
that final confrontation with trinity
and we do have another another question
it says your series has some of the cool
death scenes who's coming up with all
the gory depths of lara and why do you
like it so much what ha ha put words in
his mouth yeah I wouldn't necessarily
say that we like it so much but one of
the things that we want to do is make
sure that the that that survival has its
consequences we've we've been asked to
turn on subtitles as something that low
on a dead is definitely yeah that is a
good thing alright so while you're doing
up sorry while we're at it we can
probably take a look at some other
things here yeah
and I'll get back to answering that
question in just a minute but yeah yeah
you can see you've got the high frame
rate on but as we were saying you can
switch back and forth at any time
between high resolution and high frame
rates so if you're in high frame rate
it's 1080p but it unlocks the frame rate
so we target 60 frames per second across
the experience and then if you're in
high resolution then you're at native 4k
and we lock it at 30 K because re at 30
frames per second because we're just
throwing all the bells and whistles at
it and then you're making a few changes
but we also after we turn on subtitles
can show the difficulty mode because I
do other things that we really took is a
fan request we have individual
difficulty sliders now so not just the
overall difficulty which you can of
course change but you can adjust the
combat you can adjust the platforming
the exploration and the puzzles
independently so if you want enemies
we're giving you a huge challenge and no
regenerating health you can turn the
combat you know all the way up but if
you want Lara to give you more hints
then she'll talk to you through the
puzzles and kind of guide you in the
direction where you want to go and then
specifically there's a group called
growl get rid of white ledges you can
turn off all of the white markings in
the environment on the exploration so if
you want to be truly lost in the
environment like Lara would be you know
this will just take away the navigation
there's a bunch of other stuff that's
impacted but again it's all about
customizing the experience whether from
the graphic presentation or from the
difficulty perspective yeah I wouldn't I
would like to see more games do that
type of thing because there are like for
me maybe I have a little bit of trouble
kind of like scanning the environment
for exactly where to go I mean and
having low like those white markings
like those subtle hints of like agony I
can either jump here or like this is the
this is the golden path to get to my
objective I like having those things but
I also like raising the combat
difficulty you know I think that's
probably the because I'm still good at
games amazing but yeah I like having
that that's challenge especially in
something where there's a lot of stealth
elements there's a lot of consequences
to like kind of messing up he most epic
stealth elements so I would I would like
when I play this I would go hard on that
and maybe normal or easy on the
exploration stuff so yeah and it depends
on
like how you want to play me like it's
good to have those options you are all
set because you can just tweak all those
individually and then I will get back to
the gory death so again saying that we
it's not that we like it so much but we
do want you to feel like survival has
consequences and Laura is trapped in
survival situations and the consequence
of failing at times can be very gory so
it's never meant to be fortuitous but it
is meant to give you a little bit of
that shock that visceral okay wow these
are the stakes are really high when I
mess up yeah yeah I'm when I was playing
it like of course when you try and solve
you pick these puzzles and or when
you're trying to do like the the jumping
sequences and stuff like that of course
you know you're gonna gonna die a few
times when I was like taking it back by
like those things like oh damn I'm I
don't I don't know I see Laura like that
well you did not want to have Laura die
you're on an adventure with Laura
you should I'm juggling to succeed I
know yeah but I'm gonna be I'm gonna do
my best to make sure that we don't see
you can do it Michael I think I can do
it cool all right so here we're in
Cozumel Mexico and uh during a Day of
the Dead festivities this kind of calls
back to when we were talking about
working with cultural consultants and
trying to build the world that's you
know grounded and something that feels
real and is real yeah and we think that
that seems like this not just from the
perspective of you know a higher degree
of immersion and authenticity and sort
of grounding the world we also use it to
showcase some of Laura's character
development because you'll see a couple
lines here where she says you know I'm
not very good with crowds or you just
see how she doesn't really interact with
people and this actually has longer
themes throughout the game where over
the course of these last couple of years
that laura has been you know engaging
you know and and chasing Trinity and you
know ever since the 2013 reboot if you
think about what's happened in Laura's
life she has spent more time around the
dead than the living if you think about
you know fact that she's in tombs places
where people haven't
been you know for hundreds if not
thousands of years and yes she has
people in her life like Jonah but she's
also lost so many people it's harder for
her to form relationships and get close
to people and so this is one of the
things that we love to draw out because
over the course of the narrative and
particularly when you get to Pyke TT
like you mentioned Lara will have to
start having these you know these human
interactions that she's not used to in
the way she deals with that and the way
she deals with some situations she's in
with with Jonah are very telling about
her her development cool yeah so here in
the in cosmo mexico we're trying to
track down Dominguez yes doctor
Dominguez and so he is you'll find the
the actual leader of Trinity he was a
person of interest when he starts the
game but Lara realized that he and Mimi
find as you're following him just
through the way that he's talking to
people and the dig that he is on Lara's
telling Jonah that hey this guy I think
he's leading Trinity like he she now
thinks that spoiler alert if you haven't
played rises a to rare that he could be
directly responsible for having her
father murdered and so there's obviously
a very personal as well as a very high
stakes connection and and reason for
Lara to wanting to find this guy right
right right but when we have a question
Magnus Hansen was saying is there any
form of choice or is it like the
previous games so it this is certainly
not a you know branching storyline or
anything like that where we give you the
choice is along the hub's like we were
talking about before where you've got
the roller-coaster ride that you are on
over the course of the narrative and
then at you know it's different points
that PI TT is one of the hubs but there
are other hubs in the game as well
whenever you reach one of these hubs
then it's sort of your choice of how you
want that you know that that narrative
to play out like what kind of side
quests are you gonna go on what kind of
of challenge tombs are you gonna pursue
and then there's also choice in how you
develop Lara you know we have a lot more
flexibility in terms of the skill tree
now and in terms of the outfits that you
can craft and find so you can really
customize Lara more than you could in
any other games to make sure that you
are playing the way you want to do you
want to play more on the stealthy side
more on the Jaguar approach which is
more aggro you know more on the Explorer
side so you can you can choose what
skills you're unlocking and choose what
kind of weapons and outfits you're
crafting and mix-and-match top and
bottom of outfits that's a new thing now
in order to choose how you want to play
the game mm-hmm I might want yeah I'm
gonna remember full of dark over here
yes
cool yeah so we're trying to track them
down and see where that takes us
yes that's a here you can see that she's
realizing that dr. Dominguez is you know
is is the leader of Trinity and I love
dr. Dominguez as this foil to Laura
because when we think about Laura being
at the height of her skills and being
confident enough that she you know makes
a mistake she does actually recognize
that you know she realizes that she's
the one that triggers the Maya
apocalypse and she wants to move forward
and set things right that's just in her
nature she's gonna own up to her mistake
and she's gonna say I've now got a be
the one to stop this dr. Dominguez on
the other side he's I think a very
sympathetic villain in that you know at
times you're gonna feel like okay I can
totally understand why he's doing what
he's doing and you're gonna be able to
understand his point of view
he's absolutely Larr as equal in many
ways he's you know just as intelligent
as her he's doing what he thinks is best
for his people and for the fate of
humanity now of course you know using
the my apocalypse to cleanse the world
as you will is you know I think we can
all agree is not necessarily the right
way to go about that but but we didn't
want to be sort of this black and white
thing we wanted to be filled with gray
areas where at times you're gonna be
questioning Lara's motives and saying
wow you should you really be doing what
you're doing and at times you're gonna
really be able to understand dr.
Dominguez this point of view so I love
that that conflict in the narrative as
well sounds like dr. Dominguez is on
that that vandals tripped it you know
absolutely there are certainly some
parallels where he is looking at it as
there are sacrifices that have to be
made
for the greater good and now of course
it's his vision of the world that he's
enacting right so there's always that
level of okay well you're probably gonna
be okay right yeah that's why we're
gonna take them down yeah exactly
but I but I do like this you know
because there is that art where at the
beginning you could almost see dr.
Dominguez being in more of that heroic
role but then you realize what his
motivations are which I wasn't spoiled
but you realize what his motivations are
and you have to stop him and at the
beginning Lara
seems like you said a little bit more
stubborn a little bit more you know hey
I'm gonna do this it's only me and she
has to kind of go through that darkest
hour and then hit that that moment that
inflection point where she says all
right no this is this is not the type of
Tomb Raider I want to be and she climbs
her way out and makes things right so
she absolutely you know is the hero and
does go on that hero's journey but in
the beginning it's a little bit more of
a you know a little bit more of a gray
area yeah yeah that kind of feeds into
what I was wondering
earlier is that so I'm actually playing
now yeah talking about
Lara as a character and how she's not
exactly like a good like person
necessarily like she's not exactly
villainous but she's also not virtuous
so leading up to the release of this
game I think a lot of people like
judging from the trailers and the claims
that y'all were putting out was like oh
is she's going to be facing consequences
is is this game gonna like turn it
around on you and be like well you know
you've been killing like so many dudes
this whole time yeah and not really
thinking about it all too much so that's
for later in the game but I wanted to
ask like is is that what the approach is
and in like in what ways are you like
trying to strike that balance between
you know still like sympathizing with
Lara cuz she's been a character for so
long that a lot of people are attached
to but also saying like she's not the
best person in the world I what we
wanted to do is make sure we were taking
some risks with the narrative and with
Lara's character development and you
know this is this is the end of Lara's
origin story and it I think would have
been a lot easier for us to kind of
phone it in and say hey here's just Lara
and yep she's good all the time and yep
she's just on a straight and narrow
trajectory toward being the Tomb Raider
but we didn't want to do that and we
wanted to challenge some of your
expectations and challenge some of the
things that you think you knew about
Lara Croft and her personality now as I
mentioned absolutely she goes on the
hero's journey she recognizes that she
has made mistakes that her confidence is
getting in the way and pushing people
away and she realizes that she's been
operating closer to that lime and she's
ever been before and she she lets
herself make the decision about what
type of Tomb Raider she's gonna be but
if you look back to Tomb Raider 2013
Laura wanted to make her mark on the
world and she was trapped in a situation
where she realized that when her back
was against the wall she had what it
takes to survive you go into rise of the
Tomb Raider and Laura says alright I've
got the skills and the will and the
intelligence needed to take down Trinity
so she puts herself in harm's way for
what she thinks is right so now you go
to shadow of the Tomb Raider we wanted
to make that conflict internal it was
very very external leading up to that
there are still external forces pushing
against Lara like we said the world is
protecting its secrets Trinity is
fighting against her but her greatest
conflict is not becoming the monster
that she's fighting and we wanted her to
skirt that line we wanted to have those
moments where you're going to question
what Lara is doing and question her
motivations because then when she comes
out on the other side of it and when she
does make the right choice then that is
what her defining moment is all about
and and her being forged by external as
well as internal factors is what makes
her into the Tomb Raider that she's
meant to be so it's never a question of
us not wanting wanting Lara to be
likable but it is saying yes Lara is
gonna have to conflict her confront her
inner demons she's gonna be conflicted
that time
she is gonna be faced with the reality
of her actions having consequences you
know she will see the devastation that
she causes by some of the decisions she
makes and she's gonna have to live with
that and that's all part of her growth
oh yeah yeah I was definitely a striking
what leading up to this so yeah it's a
it's interesting to when you know I
think that games nowadays kind of they
do that thing where you know you don't
always play a completely virtuous
character so it's it's refreshing to see
Laura included in that mix yeah people
aren't completely virtuous right yeah
they are all a mix of things and I think
you know some games make it like oh
you're playing the antihero and they're
they're like the horrible person but you
have to play them you know because
because they're they're doing a good
thing or you play the shiny you know oh
my god they're they're amazingly pure
but but I actually enjoy those
narratives and I love the games where
and as you said you're starting to see a
little more of that where the characters
reflect more of who we are as people
which is a mix of both and yeah we make
mistakes and whether or not we own up
those mistakes and then set ourselves on
the right course like Lara eventually
does that to me is is what makes for a
compelling narrative I was you're
flirting with the edge of that anger
there I've I've done this many yeah
myself no wait weird so you have a we
have a mix of things we have combat we
have exploration we have different
branching tombs sandy and all that so
when you're when you're building out
like things like this where like you're
trying to get players to like scale
walls and and jump and stuff like what's
the what's kind of like your approach to
designing these kinds of sequences in
the game well so anyone do your double
tap here yeah there you go and so when
we're trying to design this again it a
lot of it comes down to how do we make
sure that the stakes feel like they're
higher and that they're challenging you
and challenging Lara in a compelling way
in a way that makes sense across the
narrative we don't want to
you know start Lara from zero every
single time because she's been all the
adventures you know if you even little
things like if you look at her character
model she's got more musculature on her
on her arms everything and she's been
climbing around the world for years now
you know she's really good like her goal
her grip strength is off the chart there
ain't nowhere to go but yeah so I you
know so in situations like that when we
when we say okay how do we design levels
we give Lara new skills you know your
ear it's showing a couple of them right
now where you've got the rappelling
you've got the wall run you've got the
rappel swing all these things are meant
to change how you're how you're
interacting with the environment and
show that as Lara's skills progress the
world is throwing more and more
difficulty at her again and keep going
back to this idea of the world isn't as
a character the world is filled with
secrets but most people can't find them
and Lara is one of the few people who
can go into these really inhospitable
environments and do what has to be done
to survive and so the secret of
immortality
the secret of you know of triggering the
Maya apocalypse is not just sitting out
you know on a pedestal somewhere for
anybody to walk up and grab these this
is the world using natural and you know
animal predators to protect its secrets
and so that's how we really approach
yeah that's how we really approach the
level design you know across the
navigation across the traversal across
the tombs like all of these things are
about the world pushing back harder than
ever and that's how we that's how we
think about the level design cool cool
yeah you can see you're going into a
tomb now yeah you know a little little
foreshadowing with the rats running away
even they don't want to be in this
situation but this is a great space to
showcase one of the new features which
is full 360 degree movement underwater
which I love is a you know a fan request
on rise of the Tomb Raider we kind of
let Lara paddle around on the surface a
little bit but now we you know be
careful what you're asking for because
we're gonna give you underwater but it's
yes become to what our survival yeah you
give us this much control we expect you
to
to have to use now use that navigation
now that you can exactly and yeah so I
mean is such a such a hard thing for
games to get right whether its control
control scheme camera or the way the
character you're controlling moves so
yeah I was um this this actually feels
like in a 3d space at least okay this is
how swimming should feel in games
because I don't want to fight against
the controllers and right so like later
on the game is there what what kind of
other things do you do with underwater
sequences throughout the game yeah well
and thank you you know we we absolutely
wanted to make sure that that the
underwater sequences weren't like oh you
should dread going underwater because
you know you never know if you're gonna
fight piranhas or moray eels but yeah
it's meant to really give you that
claustrophobic at times at other times
wide open okay I've gotta explore but
but it's always meant to feel like a
survival situation and later in the game
you will absolutely have more scenarios
where you're underwater never for too
long at the time because again we don't
want to drag down but there's gonna be
collectibles underwater there can be
resources underwater
there's even you know potentially
challenge tunes underwater also and you
have to be able to upgrade Lara's skill
with breathing for example in order to
reach your love exactly so we try and
make it so that everything feels like
it's interconnected like okay if I
upgrade Lara's breathing you know the
ability to hold her breath not only can
I swim around more and maybe get the
jump on Trinity soldiers you know cuz I
could stealth underwater takedown oh
yeah I can't do it like so you get the
underwater takedowns on on the soldiers
but you also have the ability to explore
further into tunnels that maybe have a
challenge to around cool yeah that's one
of the things that generator what I play
tries at the Tomb Raider and I was like
just how how much exploration there is
and like the things that are on the
other end
depends on what you want out of the game
but in many cases like these things are
like rewarding if not for like actual
like tangible rewards but also you know
exploration is the reward itself oh dear
so we know we don't get no no scary
death looking yes just darkness sorry I
was getting a little antsy but well yes
we want that we want the exploration to
be a reward in and of itself
you know the traversal in the tomb so
you're in a tomb now and you've got you
know this idea of the the counterweights
you have to balance things out in order
to progress there there are certainly
collectibles off the beaten path
you know sometimes exploration will be
I'm gonna find a challenge to them when
we're gonna find a weapon the crypts you
know our back we introduced crypts and
in Rises a Tomb Raider and now they're
as large as some of the smaller
challenge students were and the
challenge tombs are as large as some of
the smaller tombs were in rise the Tomb
Raider so everything got bigger there's
more of the tombs because we know that's
what our fans are looking for but that
that exploration is absolutely integral
to the to the game plan and then we have
a question in terms of the horror net
did you do any horror or tension
building scenes like the one underwater
yes so we we absolutely try and find
that balance I mean obviously it's not a
horror game but what we wanted to do
it's behind you
okay you know go around that yeah right
there again really dark yeah it's super
dark to see down that way okay there
yeah so left then so yes we absolutely
look at how can we build tension in
particular in tombs where we want the
tombs to be one of Lara's greatest
challenges and it also fits in with the
with the culture because this was you
know a culture that celebrated sacrifice
and fear and we wanted to make sure that
the that that these tombs reflected
so as Laura's navigating her way through
these tombs she should constantly be
reminded that very few people can
survive here Jeff yes good question
just so everyone knows my good friend
Eric Tay here is messing with the
controls on the TV so I was a you know
check out what was going on with that
real quick but I think we should be okay
and I move the brightness up yeah there
we're playing with yeah today you're
playing with super bright lights in your
eyes which is all against an already
dark place so so kudos to you on making
it through with only one death so far
yeah we should have a deathcounter over
here yeah exactly
ding in the corner hey just one what is
it woman
one too many you asked me oh that's
alright
it was good it shows people that it's
not recorded right it's like hey this
solves a lot it's authentic yeah this is
a real game play yeah we're not you
thought you were watching a cinematic
the entire time
no people the graphics are just that
good yeah
even with like 2013 uh Tomb Raider it
was kind of like one of the marquee
games in terms like benchmarking thank
you now we're going on to like Tom about
like the PC version of these games and
then Rises the Tomb Raider especially
was like okay now this is like a
benchmark game so thank you after all
these years I mean I think like the the
graphical push this time is just like
having those different environments so
is that all like a concern like through
the development process like how we need
to have like the best looking game like
how are we gonna like be better than the
then like you know God of War or like is
that Metro last light was like a very
long for a while that game was very much
like a benchmark game so is that all any
of quite concerned with the development
team or y'all like thinking about that
as you make this game I you know I think
it's less about oh we have to be better
than this or that you know we're all we
all love games and so from from our
perspective when when the industry as a
whole has great looking games we just
think everybody wins for Mark part we
try to make sure that the things that
are
important to the franchise really shine
and so we are always looking to push you
know the the tech is as far as possible
at you know like like I was saying
earlier you know on on xbox 1x you've
got that full HDR support you've got you
know the dolby atmos we've got the you
know the new more immersive immersive
foliage but that's not just to take a
bunch of boxes it's because we're saying
hey we're putting lara in the jungle and
that needs to feel alive and we want to
then push the tech as far as possible to
do that so that you can feel like you're
on an adventure with Laura and then we
look at Lara's character model we are
always trying to make sure that Laura
looks amazing she is the star of the
show so when I talked earlier about you
know the musculature and and you know
Laura's hair we pay you would not
believe how much attention we pay to
long hair you know that's it's very
important yeah it's so so it's really
about what are the things that we really
feel helped us tell our story and are
important to the franchise and the world
and Lara obviously the world encompasses
a lot of things but that's really where
we try and focus our time so we're
always happy to be held as a benchmark
we're always very grateful when people
say that and we always try and outdo
ourselves with each game coup I luckily
I've done this puzzle before so this was
a tricky one yeah so so I played this at
e3 and I was like no no don't tell me
how to do this I know how to do this
they said I was really I could see you
figuring it out yeah but it's also good
because you're mimicking the the player
experience the first time player
experience is gonna be
if I try this - what you're doing yeah
it's anyone who hasn't started yet
here's the tip - video right here - I
solved that puzzle yeah speaking of
puzzles who designs these things man we
have some really really talented people
including one one guy on the itis
Montreal team who did a lot of research
into what resources and technology and
you know sort of mechanisms were
available at the times - I just slipped
off the I know that was that was just we
won't start that one well count that one
good - to what resources were available
at the times to the point where he
actually had working like Lego and you
know tinker toy models of a lot of them
oh my god
gonna be a little faster it's all right
oops it's three that is definitely bad
yeah third time's the charm but he built
out obviously this is probably a little
bit more sophisticated than you would
find if you were to go you know into
into the Maya architecture but the idea
was they were very you know advanced
people they built incredible things and
all of these puzzles and traps and
mechanisms that we have in the game are
theoretically possible using the tools
that they have it so it's like the
matically fitting between exactly the
puzzles and the actual environments that
you are building along with the story
that you're trying to tell absolutely
and the other thing that we did is again
in keeping with the toons being you know
absolutely terrifying and deadlier than
ever before even the puzzle elements
will kill you once you get far enough to
know so even failing at a puzzle
solution can result in Lara dying so
yeah we again we have to hope there's
plenty of ups the stakes yes if you're
playing on any of the normal difficulty
I'll get plenty of auto-saves it's only
when you put it on deadly obsessions you
can see is difficulty yeah then you can
only save the camps so then it starts to
that you want to talk about
white-knuckle experience like that when
you're like okay if I miss this jump or
this puzzle I lose an hour of gameplay
that's when you start to sweat just a
bit yeah
yeah cuz then for example like here when
I'm doing these puzzles I'm like I'll
try the jump if that's if that doesn't
work then I'll test something else or
like when the first time I was playing
sati 3 and before launch I think month
ago is like oh I'm just gonna make try
and make this jump I think that's where
I'm supposed to go yeah like ok but I
wasn't
so I'm just like jumping here jumping
yeah like falling all the times and then
the people who want to play with no
white markings
that's what boggles my mind so I just
respect to all you guys out there who do
that but the the idea of losing an hour
worth of gameplay because you're jumping
at a cliff and you have no idea whether
you can hang on to it or not that is
that is hardcore
I'm so happy to get yeah but if you did
my hat is off to all of you who attempt
deadly obsession across the board that
is a it's quite achievement yeah yeah I
remember when I would play like Tom
Clancy's Splinter Cell or any of the top
points of games that are low those games
yeah yeah I would play at the highest
difficulty because I don't know there's
something about those moments where
especially Splinter Cell a stealth game
which shadow Tomb Raider has a lot of in
it I think that you know having guards
you know on high alert or having their
sight lines is like realistic as
possible it's kind of like that's kind
of my jam so you know having that
opportunity to do that here with the
difficulty changes is pretty dope so and
you guys recommended that you play I
remember the feature you did you know
yeah Tomb Raider I would say for the
combat I think absolutely if you're
looking for a challenge you know I think
the normal combat is for people who want
to be able to make their way through the
story and not have too much of a
challenge from the Trinity soldiers but
as soon as you start upping the
difficulty on the combat which again is
great because you can do that
independently of the other ones that
that's how I like to play I up the
difficulty on the combat but I I keep
the white markings and yeah and I
probably I actually to up the difficulty
on the puzzles as well because I like to
figure that out
yeah give me two minutes yeah it's when
I'm playing at like events and stuff
especially at e3 and like I know people
are watching me so I'm just gonna like
yeah I don't want to stumble there you
gotta put a little show on yeah yeah
yeah okay we're probably gonna get into
some combat soon yes so we're gonna see
a little taste of how stealth and actual
shooting balance with each other I
really like using the bow and arrow I
think that's my favorite that's my
weapon of choice just like its it feels
pretty like satisfying to line up that
shot at the right time and like when
you're pulling back on the ball like
Paula Kate I'm lining this up during its
patrol pattern so yeah we're gonna get a
little bit of that hopefully yes
absolutely and I you know I I think the
bow just as one of you know Lara's
signature elements I've always loved
that throughout the series and so just
like the other games you have multiple
bows you have different upgrade parts
you can apply to it you know lots of
different bow skills that you can that
you can acquire so you can absolutely go
full force into the bow but you're also
seeing some of the new combat tactics
that Lara has it or dispossess so you
know hiding up against vine walls later
on you'll be able to cut yourself in mud
so you can have those predators style
takedowns I really loved that because it
shows Lara becoming one with the jungle
and that's one of our key tenets of the
game which is that Lara's going into
these environments she is you know
outgunned and outnumbered by Trinity but
she is not outsmarted you know that she
is gonna make all the things that are
deadly at first to her work to her
advantage eventually and there's
actually a moment later on in the game
where Laura is is coming up against a
Jaguar and she's at first taken aback
and she kind of sets her gaze and she's
like okay I've got this and that she's
reaching for her bow she gets attacked
from behind by another one is that the
first Jaguar was just a distraction and
from that point on she realizes okay
I've got to become one with the jungle
we actually refer to her you know
internally as the Jaguar woman because
she is striking and disappearing like
the Jaguar does
making Trinity feel like they don't know
where the next attack is coming from it
and that also plays up the fear in
combat where you can string a soldier up
from a tree and his cohorts will see him
what's going on you can cut your arrows
with a toxin that will make them
hallucinate and shoot each other you
know really making it feel like the
jungle itself is coming alive and then
one of the other things that we did is
change it so if you break stealth and
you go into the more aggressive combat
if you evade capture long enough
nice headshots if you evade capture long
enough you can actually get back into
stealth you know be be this soldiers
will lose sight of you so those are the
types of things that I like because just
makes you feel like you've got more
options in combat yeah yeah I think that
I'm curious about this in particular is
that you have a lot of these new tools
like going into mud hiding and vines
those contextual stealth kills and you
have bone arrow and you've got guns too
but the challenge with that is building
levels that are conducive to using those
things
can you speak to like some of the like
the design philosophies when like
creating something like this we're
looking at right here which is a baby an
early level so it's a design and a way
to kind of teach you what you can and
can't exactly but later on the game I
suppose that there would be a lot more
intricate level design so what's kind of
the thinking behind designing these
combat sequences yes well we want to
make sure is feel like that that we're
scaling the combat along with you you
know so this is giving you plenty of
opportunities to do you know aerial
takedowns like takedowns from beneath
using the vine walls using the the bow
using the machine guns using the
explosive so this is kind of a little
toy box this is basically other than the
first boat tutorial this is your first
compact moment so this is your toy box
so you can start to figure out how do I
want to play you could have gone in here
agro guns blazing and you would have you
know that's just as much chance of
success Oh
yeah now you've got some stray shoulders
coming after you you're gonna have to be
agri for a little bit but later on it is
about making sure that you feel like you
have options so we try and set the
combat encounters up so that you could
go in guns blazing although I will say
it is much more difficult to do so in in
shadow of the generator than it was in
previous games especially if you play on
the harder difficulties yeah and you can
start to use all the different tactics
that you're learning so if you want to
play more stealthy if you want to play
more aggro we try and give you enough
options that you can do that and give
you enough combat pockets that you can
do that I will also say that there's
there is actually a little bit less
combat in shadow of the Tomb Raider we
tried to find a little bit more of a
balance there's there's more of a focus
while there's still obviously plenty of
combat as you can see here we have more
tunes more exploration you know bigger
hubs so there's a lot there's a lot more
focus on that exploration component and
then we have combat you know probably
it's about a third a third a third now
whereas before combat felt like it was
more than a third yeah that was like the
names of your games essentially so how
do you paste that out though I think
that's a that's something that I would
say it anyone overlooks but it's a
tricky thing to get and sometimes it's a
you know it's hard to like I want it
like as someone who makes games like I
imagine that you just like I just want
to have all this stuff in there I want
everyone to see it but how do you kind
of like make sure that you're leading
them in the right directions and you're
like giving them a little bit of
everything throughout the game without
staying on one beat for too long like
can you speak to any of that yes what
we'll do is is map out and you can see
the soldiers are searching for your
hidden in the wall like I had a little
problem I look at this and find the we
will map out the entire game experience
oh here you go good chance all right I
know that they see me oh yeah I got
got a guy here yet you can see me now
out of here break site yeah you got some
all right okay you can do this shot guys
you know I really like the Latinos truck
it has a lot of punch yeah there we go
well done oh man we'll map out the
entire game and you know we'll have beat
documents that will let us see exactly
where you know in each level but combats
gonna be the exploration and again it's
about trying to take people on a roller
coaster you know we want you to feel
like alright I don't know what's coming
next
and we want to keep the players guessing
and we obviously have to make sure that
you're getting you know sort of your
fill of combat you know I'm what I call
the red meat action fan so I absolutely
want that combat I want that moment a
moment yes I want to upgrade my weapons
and my bows and I want to do cool
takedowns and so we have to make sure we
still have that and along the core path
that's really the one thing that you
can't you know avoid is the combat you
can stealth your way around you can
avoid some encounters but you're gonna
have to go through Trinity one way or
another um it's really the rest of the
game where we then can can find more of
that okay let's put a ton of exploration
over here you know that's completely
optional is put a ton of tunes ever here
that's completely optional so that's how
we try and find that balance where
there's some stuff that you can choose
to do and some stuff that you get a so
as part of the course whatever your
favorite part of the game is you can act
you can find it exactly all right we got
we got Dominguez over here he uh he got
our got our dagger that he installed the
dagger that we stole so everyone's
stealing from each other mhm yeah what
is it this dagger has got some mystical
power this is this is what they call
this the key you know this is the key of
shock shell and the thing I love about
this scene is it first
dr. Dominguez is not even mad at Lara
he's like no don't hurt her he's like
okay now give me the box and that's what
that's what's happening right now I know
we're talking over it so maybe it's a
little harder to see but he's basically
looking at her saying okay now give me
the box like he looks at her like we're
kindred spirits we you've got the dagger
I want the dagger now give me the box
that's the true side of an evil person
exactly and then
and he realizes she doesn't have it he's
incredulous like right now he is saying
do you know what you've done yeah so he
at first expected her to have both
together and now she feels like it's up
to him to fix her mistake it's almost
like he's it's appointed it hurt do you
know what you just did you took the key
without having the corresponding box and
the key of shock shell in the box of
eggshell those things go together and
that's what gives you the power to
remake the world but without it that's
what triggers the my apocalypse so this
is perfect example if we were talking
about earlier where Laura felt like I'm
the only one who can stop Trinity Jonah
was saying hang on now Laura let's let's
think about this and she says no I have
to take the key right now to stop
Trinity from getting it and that is what
causes the devastation that's about to
unfold and Laura has to confront that
she has to basically accept that she
played a large role now obviously if
Trinity wasn't hunting for it she never
would have been there in the first place
so it's not like Laura caused it I was
she bought rigueur tea yeah like she
played a huge role by not stopping and
waiting and that's why she feels like
she has to right that wrong
yeah so he's like I thought you were the
Tomb Raider exactly I thought you had
this figured out yeah so he's now he's
he's mad disappointed disappointed Joan
is that look on his face you know
disappointed by the rest that way I
don't know how that would make me yeah I
know
oh jeez oh yeah so this is the ad this
sequence is pretty devastating yes
here there's like there's a lot of you
paint a pretty clear picture of the
devastation and the death that happens
in this town but I imagine that that's
like a kind of a like a difficult thing
to do where you're kind of like painting
so much so much death around or it is so
how do you how do you toad that line
between like okay we want to let the
player know that she really messed up
and there's a consequence there are
consequences to what she's doing but
also like I wouldn't say like making
sure it's peaceful I don't think that's
the law the right word
but something that just like you almost
feel her to it is right yeah and you're
right it is a line and it is when I
spoke earlier about us wanting take some
risks with the narrative this is one of
them because having these big you know
we call them you know run out you know
high-octane action sequences in the
franchise it's not the first time you
know in 2013 you had you know the water
one you had the plane crash one and rise
of the Tomb Raider we start very early
with the avalanche media you know but
this was the first time that we made one
of these high-octane action sequences
actually come with with you know
devastation and loss of human life all
around Lara and again that was one of
the risk we wanted to take because up
until this point you know Lara's not
very good for tombs you know she's doing
what she thinks is right there she goes
into a tomb normally bad things happen
you know to the collapses or she goes
into an environment and avalanche is
triggered this is the first time the
Lara's confronted by these very real
consequences and the loss of life and
the devastation that hits these town
this town is one of the things she has
to own up to she has to own that and you
know this this is also where we can
really start to fray that relationship
with her and Jonah yeah because Jonah's
as you'll see is is incredibly impacted
by this and he is you know up through
the bus window [ __ ] okay it's around he
is
he's incredibly upset by this you know
and this is a spot where you know if
Jonah who's been with Lara through thick
and thin is now basically questioning
her motives and her actions you know
that things have have reached higher
stakes than they ever have before
and that also is something that Laura's
gonna have to deal with and try and
repair that relationship which is if
Jonah so it was a tough balance and it
is tricky to show this in a way that
doesn't feel good to us but it really
was necessary for us to show you that
the stakes are higher than ever before
Lara has still got some growing to do in
terms of figuring out what kind of Tomb
Raider she's going to become and to show
you that if even Lara and Jonah are not
on the same side you know in terms of
how they're seeing this situation the
other things have have come apart in the
way that they never have before right
right and I think that what now that I
think about it I think it's it can go
one way or another but when you start
like the Cozumel sequence with so much
world building and showing that like
people live here and yeah and then when
you essentially destroyed the town I
mean that must be like kind of like a
tough thing to design it is and it's but
it is also as you said you know I did as
you were talking about earlier bringing
people into the world and showing that
this celebration ends in devastation you
know if you're paying attention you'll
recognize some of the people that you
interacted with Oh earlier seem like
actually losing their lives here in fact
you know as you come around this corner
you're gonna see the kid this was the
kid with the sparkler
that you had the option functionally to
to the optional optional
that's a good job okay you had the
optional option to optionally speak with
and so it's it's again not meant to be
cry to attest but to be that Lara had a
brief moment of connection with this kid
in you know during the celebration and
all that comes undone and that hopefully
again serves as a sort of a very
poignant reminder of the stakes of
of what's going on in the game mm-hmm
yeah I imagine that that's that's a
tough thing to kind of design and also
like trying to test out how people will
respond to it it's also tough because
you don't want to show your game early
and anything anything like that so yeah
I'm curious to see like how that carries
on throughout the game as well and I
don't know when we were we talked a lot
about you know the conflict between
Jonah and Lauren you can see it playing
out right here where she's like very
concerned about herself and her journey
and then John was like yo hold up you
just needed this so yeah this is the
first example where do you see things
kind of falling apart right right well
and this is and again Laura's doing what
she thinks is right
Lara has been through a lot she's been
through more than most people could
possibly deal with and she feels like
she is the only one who can go after
Trinity and that and that has blinded
her to what's going on it's so it's not
that Laura thinks she's being selfish or
wants personal glory or anything like
that but she believes that no one is
safe she believes that if she doesn't
stop Trinity that the entire world is
going to suffer and Jonah is saying it's
not just you you're not the only one and
we are gonna help these people right now
and then we'll go off and stop Trinity
so that that's that conflict of Laura's
saying no there's no time we have to
just go and Jona forcing her to take
stock and realize no you cannot just put
this in your rearview mirror you have to
look at what has happened and deal with
influence that that's what's a really
important message yeah I don't want to
spoil anything but I'm sure that later
on in the game it does it does and you
know it
especially when Laura starts to get like
the pie TT and she's forced to deal with
people and as you have continued
interactions with dr. Dominguez and with
Jonah that theme is gonna play out and
and right now you know this is Laura on
her way down like she is plummeting
toward you know her darkest moment like
for her state of rehearse David being
and that's that inner conflict that I
was talking about where she now feels
like she's failed she's forced as you
can see that to look straight on at the
devastation that she's had a part in
causing
and soon after this we start that's when
we start that upward trajectory of her
saying no I I have to be a more
responsible Tomb Raider I have
that's her defining moment is how she
climbs out of that okay I was gonna say
something oh um I was listening to a
discussion about Tomb Raider and we're
you you know it's we talked about
balancing like Laura as like a good or
bad character you know but it plainly
mm-hm
and talking about how she she hits like
it almost an all-time low and it has to
come back up it's very much about her so
how do you balance now like a game
that's about her and like making
something that doesn't necessarily
revolve around her because there's also
an active world that that that happens
without her so like when you go to PI TT
right like things are happening without
like her control so it do you kind of
feel that throughout the games that's
something that was considered like okay
this is this is essentially Lara's story
but there is a world beyond her there is
and you know one of the decisions we
made was to have fewer supporting
characters so that we really have more
depth to people and there's some people
that we haven't really introduced yet so
I don't want to avoid but we wanted to
have a smaller cast overall so that
Lara's interactions with them could be
more meaningful and we could develop
them more and there's people that you
will meet in pike TT who play a
significant role in the story but then
just when you get to Pyke TT itself it
is the first time that Lara is basically
finding a living tomb because this is a
world that's untouched by you know
modern times and they have their own
ecosystem they have their own you know
their own life and how Lara has to
interact and fit into that and he's
accepted by that culture is is also part
of her growth so we wanted to really set
Lara up to feel more alone than she ever
has and to have pushed away people
whichever side before because then the
the the relationships that she forges on
the way up you know we think have even
more weight yeah it's like putting her
taking her outside her comfort zone in a
way okay I see you mm-hmm
and you get to see you know one of my
favorite moments in the game you know
happens when you get to the first no
sorry the second hub
the first hub is one that you're just
about to have Kawana yes so yeah when
you get to that village there's this
moment where you know Laura is having
interaction which I've mixed boy looks
like is I want people to experience
themselves but where it's her and Jonah
and another character have this
conversation and you could just see how
uncomfortable Laura is at the Jolla
where she's she's never had or not never
been it's been so long since she's had
normal human interactions like oh you're
right yeah they've just aren't about to
rating and and I laugh out loud every
time I see it but it's also I think just
- it's a it's a striking reminder of how
much Lara has isolated herself in the
pursuit of yeah this you know she's been
like - and so like almost like tunnel
vision in a way with like her father's
research and like tracking these dudes
down so like when you do have to
interact with these uh because there's a
lot more life and culture in Chadha
little areas like Rises almost like it's
set up in a way it's like off surviving
this like harsh environment and now it's
kind of like I'm trying to navigate
these different cultures in these
different people so yeah that you
mentioned it's like oh yeah okay this is
why she acts in this way when we get to
Kohaku and then I'm curious it's like
how that carries on to other hub worlds
yeah
yeah just a lot going on so here yes
there's a devastating plane crash yes
that was a plane crash from the very
beginning so now we are okay yeah so now
we are all timeline all caught up so
unfortunately we don't have too much
more time but I think I want to kind of
like walk around see a little bit of the
vegetation and kind of soak in the world
a little bit more because then from here
if you if you're going to play this game
from here's when things start to open up
yes it's a first fire camp you see the
skill trees
then you start to get into like that
Jaguar fight right there yeah it's a
crafting you get your skill um lots you
know this is where you've got some this
this is the first this is the smallest
of the hubs you know we usually call
these the we refer to them as hunting
grounds internally because they're the
smallest because again we don't want to
just throw you in and have you not know
yeah be like anyway overwhelmed but
you've got some challenge tombs that are
in this area you've got some side quests
and and and one of the questions was
asked are there any side missions
absolutely so course this is that first
real space where you are just dropped
into the middle of this area you don't
know where to go and there's a lot to do
yeah and one of the things that I love
about how we approach the world is at
first you can see just everything is
very very dark and impressive and you
know the jungle itself is not a lot of
sunlight coming through as you progress
through the game we actually make the
jungle start to get brighter and lighter
and you have more direction around where
to go and that's that's also mirroring
Laura's growth okay cuz as she becomes
one with the jungle
she becomes you know she sort of becomes
a part of it yeah so it's like
understand as a jungle how to navigate
it there's a there's a great moment
where she's face to face and people may
have seen it from the trailer she's face
to face with this Jaguar yeah and it
almost looks at her like okay I'm not
sure what to make of you but I kind of
respect you so um so we try and have
moments like that that you know where
the world is is is sort of parallel is a
parallel like you said like having the
world as a character yeah and something
that evolves over time mm-hmm that's
just not just static mm-hmm so let me
see I'm gonna there's a jumping sequence
I'm running on trees and after this like
yes and then after that I think the fire
camp is yes although it'll be to the
first camp okay cool and it basically
might
my tree and then call it yeah because I
definitely want to show I definitely
want to show the skill tree because
that's definitely interesting you take
some dates over here
oh that's of you whatever yeah if every
with a moment narrow later yeah oh we
should have maybe we should have made
lara grab an egg right there that was
been good just have bought eggs man
that's how you stay at Isis well so she
stays yoked Oh get it yeah all right
that was terrible
no it's good man no I'm a fan I don't
fan a very very bad pun you actually
just started a slack channel with
actually no typos titles can also be
ponds but like we're a fan that's a so
I'm on the editorial team so anything
that has to do with really bad writing
yeah that's so bad it's good oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm into the dad jokes at home
with the kids now yes oh man yeah that's
good all right yeah here we go we're in
the first camp yes here so uh let's
check out some skills
yeah the first thing you'll notice is
that everything is on one screen so this
is what we're talking about before
trying to give you more flexibility and
some things you'll unlock over the
normal course of the story other things
you'll in Locke based on how you decide
to play like where you want to unlock
your skill tree and you can see that you
here right now you're in the in a
scavenger area so this is more the
exploration you can go with the warrior
or you can go with with if you go up you
going to the seeker so depend on how you
want to play like the stealthy or the
more aggro or the more exploration yeah
it's kind of similarly as the game is
broken up the skill trees is also broken
up in that way cool yeah I always go
from ami I need help in combat because
I'm gonna play on all right very cool
warrior skills so what about these
unlock ones can tell me what some of
these unlock ones do well some of them
are get yes some of you'll get over the
course of the story
those are ones that have like sort of
the book open okay some of them you'll
get by finding challenge tombs so we
want to make sure that you're getting
material rewards yeah one sense if I
challenge Jun so you'll get a new skill
that can then
one's how you how you play the game
alright so here I need to get my
equipment and you tied down these ropes
cuz my stuff is in that box right there
but instead of doing that which might
take a minute I think we can uh you got
to get your machete oh that's right
because there's there's a challenge
tumor around here but I think I need
equipment to get to that yes yeah so
that you have to first get the machete
so you can get your gear and then once
you get your gear they have you chop all
that challenge - yeah alright well
that's uh let's see oh man we're running
over we ran over our time limit sorry
Tay sorry jean-luc I know y'all got work
to do today but uh yeah this is um I
think this is where we'll kind of shut
it down yeah it's a good good nice
little you can show people the promise
of the first hub stretching out the
limitless possibilities yeah yeah I
really like guys yeah soon after this it
gets a kawaki aku and I think that I
like that a lot because it really
showcases like a village trying to like
hold itself together and just like a lot
of like good character even though
that's the first small hub world mm-hmm
I think it gives you a good taste of
what's to come for the rest of it so
really yeah I think that'll be it for
our stream and if everyone's interested
and what you saw today shadow the Tomb
Raider is available now right yes early
access is live right now so if you have
the Croft edition or the season pass you
can start playing right away otherwise
it's available on Xbox one X and ps4 and
PC on Friday okay is there anything you
want to add before we uh before we say
bye to everyone watching out there well
thanks a lot for having me on thanks a
lot for tuning in and we're really
excited to have you guys experienced
Lara Croft's defining moment stakes
couldn't be higher it's Lara at her most
confident or most capable and she's
going up against Trinity to stop the
Maya apocalypse so guys to experience it
it's a lot going on so yeah you can if
you just tuned in to the stream you
could probably watch the replay
afterwards to see the beginning parts of
that we also have that piece on why you
should play this game on the hardest
difficulty so go check that out we also
have the review on the site and all
kinds of content for Shadow the Tomb
Raider again this is rich Briggs senior
brand director the square Enix got to
get that title right here joining me
today too
a little bit the game and talk about it
thank you so much man I really like it
appreciate it all right for all you out
there stick the gamespot.com
for all our good stuff we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you